hey guys it's Tuesday August sixteenth
I'm Mary and you're watching gamespot
news first step overwatch continues to
make players happy this week by making
high bandwidth servers default on PC and
a new map the custom game option will
increase the client update rate from 21
times per second to 63 this reduces the
amount of time between when you complete
an action and when your client hears
back about the result which in turn will
make the game feel more responsive a
blizzard forum post explained for those
with slower internet connections it has
added in tech that will automatically
and adaptively scale down your update
rate if they find that your connection
can't keep up but shut up and get to the
map you say you got it blizzard
announced at Gamescom today that a new
map is headed to overwatch I can Valda
is the first post launch map to be added
to the game it's set in Germany and
features a castle and its neighboring
village it goes live in September during
the blizzard gamescom stream overwatch
lead system designer Aaron Keller said
the play area is very vertical in the
middle of the map additionally you have
to cross a draw bridge that leads to a
castle at the end of the map sounds like
this is going to be a good Widowmaker
spot Keller also explained bastions
original skin which makes the turret
touting robot look like it came from a
forest is from this map Blizzard also
gave a sneak peek at the first episode
of the second overwatch animated series
starring Bastion that episode fully
releases on Thursday over the next two
weekends titanfall tues open beta or
technical test as they want to call it
it's coming out on xbox one and ps4 the
first of the two weekend beta is
starting Friday August nineteenth with
two modes and two maps available the
following weekend will offer that same
content but with an additional map and
mode added into the mix you're getting
two new titans ion and scorch along with
pilot abilities like grapple
hollow-point and pulse blade there's two
interesting weapons for you to use to
the Mastiff which is a horizontal spread
shotgun and the alternator a dual barrel
SMG those are both featured in the
trailer you're seeing
now the beta runs from August nineteenth
through the 21st while the second runs
August twenty sixth through the 28th the
beta will only be available on consoles
respawn decided to skip PC because it
wasn't optimized enough yet EA said the
beta begins on Friday but they didn't
say a time so who knows the full game
launches on october 28th if you want
more info on those game modes and how
the titans are playing you're going to
want to check out GameSpot's coverage we
released several videos today a new
patch for no man's sky is on its way and
hello games has said that it's going to
make people very happy at the very least
hopefully just not angry no man's sky
launch for ps4 a week ago but it's the
PC Edition only having launched on
August twelfth that's running into a few
problems in response to the issues which
included crashes and framerate drops
hello games launched in experimental
branch that certain players could join
and play a version of the game with
these changes applied before the release
to everyone Sean Murray said on Twitter
that the patch is going to make people
very happy but we don't know if he's
referring to this branch even though
it's not confirmed what's in this branch
well you're getting improved AMD support
improved alt-tab shader caching fixing
issues with mouse jitter fixing
stuttering issues due to the max FPS cap
and overall improve performance you can
check out the full list of all that
stuff the experimental branch is
supposed to solve on gamespot and that's
all the news I have for you today but
I'll see you guys again tomorrow have a
good one
you